herzlich willkommen liebe eltern
familienangehörige freunde und
freundinnen der rekruten des heims
termines märz 2021 ich befinde mich am
standort hier in feldbach in der von der
groeben kaserne und der verband ist das
auge und erträgen der sieben
jägerbrigade und für ein wesentlicher
träger der militärischen
landesverteidigung nachrichten gewinnung
und aufklärung ja und er hat bereits in
der mitte des platzes aufgenommen ist
der kommentar ausgerückten gruppe herr
oberstleutnant martin j von bruder
vorher erfolgt nun die übergabe der
standard life of canada reporter und
sieben aus feldbach
militärmusik steiermark er entzog an zu
geloben der rekruten ein rhythmus termin
oktober 2020 auf mein kommando
ich spreche sie an als das ganze das
ganze habt acht ehrenzug präsentiert zum
einmarsch des insignia clubs das ganze
recht schon insignien tropisch
einzige truppe affäre zu wer das ganze
[Musik]
es ist ein besonderer festakt daher ist
natürlich auch der ehrenzug hier
ausgedrückt und der kommandant
vizeleutnant war thema
steiner und musikalisch umrahmt wird die
veranstaltung durch ein ensemble der
militärmusik steiermark s register
führer und musik und auf ist ja
wachtmeister hansi kraus ja und wir
starten musikalisch durch mit olympic
fanfare
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit sind die höchsten
repräsentanten des heutigen tages
eingetreten eingetroffen
in kürze erfolgt das ankündigung signale
danach meldet der kommentaren der
ausgerückten truppe brigade kommandant
ein brigadier magister horst hofer den
beginn der feierlichkeiten
unmittelbar danach erklingt die
bundeshymne und danach werden die
höchsten repräsentanten die front der
truppe abschreiten beginnend beim
ensemble der militärmusik steiermark auf
der innenseite der truppe geht ab riga
die kommentare und rechts verändern der
stellvertretende bataillonskommandeur
oberstleutnant stocker
[Musik]
das ganze ab 8
er rennt zu pressen wird
zur meldung an den kommentaren der 7
denn der leichten jägerbrigade das ganze
rechts
labbadia ich melde ein ensemble der
militärmusik steiermark den in syke und
trug des aufklärungs harry potter und
sieben gestellt durch das kommando den
ehren zugestellt durch die stabskompanie
aufklärungsrate und 750 an zu gelogen
der rekruten aus feldbach von
aufklärungssatelliten 7 und vom jäger
vater und zwölf aus amstetten sowie den
einrichtungs termin oktober 2020 aus
feldbach zum festtag der angelobung mit
dem festakt beginnen
[Musik]
capriati ich melde mich ab
das ganze hab acht gb ab das ganze roth
es erfolgt nun das hissen der dienst
flagge des bundes stolz werden sie
hießen herr wachtmeister mario gutmair
herr wachtmeister robert kovacic und
herr wachtmeister rené ortmüller
das ganze habe er den zug präsentiert
flagge hissen
zur flaggenparade das ganze recht
[Musik]
das ganze acht ehrenzug gewehr ab das
ganze roth die begrüßung der ehrengäste
erfolgs auf den stellvertretenden
valognes kommentar oberstleutnant
manfred sträucher
ich darf sie aus stellte der
bataillonskommandant des
aufklärungsbataillons 7
das in afrika als stellvertreter konzern
com rand der von der grüns gerne als
stellvertreter tag keine chance kommt
der garnison feldberg zum festakt
anlässlich der heutigen angelobung und
sprechen das treuegelöbnis durch die
grundwerte des entwicklungsstandes wert
2021 kameradschaftlich und heute sogar
bei sonnigem frühlingswetter hier im
raabtal im vulkanland das wird
oststeiermark begrüßen persönlich
begrüßen darf ich den militärischen
höchst am besten und seine private
kameraden der sieben jägerbrigade aus
klagenfurt herrn brigadier mag ist der
horst hofer der brigadier danke für ihr
kommen
weiters begrüßen darf ich den commander
offizier der fabrikate denn hier haben
die zu leighton hat ferdinand offene
meer zu leiten und danke für ihre
anwesenheit vom militärkommando
steiermark aus graz dafür unsere
militärseelsorge der römisch katholische
militärpfarrer der militärdekan militär
kaplan magister johannes freitag somit
evangelische militärpfarrer den
amtsdirektor manfred wahl gramm sowie
der herren in sohland karl-heinz
buchecker hier in feldbach begrüßen
meine herren militärseelsorge dankeschön
für ihre geistige und geistliche worte
so wie htc und dankeschön für ihre
unterstützung für die organisation und
live streaming und übertragung der
heutigen angelobung willkommen heiße ich
das militär sampl
die militärmusik mit dem argument der
steiermark us grad kamera
danke für eure musikalische umrahmung
des festaktes ein dankeschön gilt weiter
das team vom heeres bild und film
mit der außenstelle von wien sie
ermöglichen heute die liveübertragung
des festaktes von feldbach haus und ich
darf mit auch in der zusammenarbeit
unserer und offiziere der
öffentlichkeitsarbeit des bataillons
denn haben für schlager andreas sowie
den stab samstag als christian für die
mitorganisation des festaktes im
wirtschaftlich denken von der groeben
kaserne darf ich begrüßen in vertretung
des vorsitzenden des den ställen
ausschusses der vor der kaserne und in
der verantwortung die personalvertretung
herrn offiziers stellvertreter werden
aber man hoffe zu stellvertreter danke
für das 1
in vertretung der unteroffizier
gesellschaft steiermark mit der
zweigstelle von der groeben kaserne hat
sich entschuldigen lassen darf ich
trotzdem den herrn mit sagen wir einen
kick meyer ansprechen der die ehre
erwiesen hatte und die besten grüße
ausrichten lässt
ein besonders kameradschaftliches grüß
gott darf ich haben all jenen wünschen
wir den gang bringen und hier möchte ich
alle freunde und freundinnen alle
angehörige und zuseher zu hause die auf
livestream den festakt mit verfolgen
begrüßen euch allen ein steirisches
ressort nun zu ihnen meine geschätzten
grundwehrdiener des entwicklungsstudios
märz 2021
sie sind am ersten märz je nach feldbach
angereist hinter vor der kaserne
eingerückt mit dem einberufungsbefehl in
der hand wohl wissend dass ihre nächsten
sechs monate die wehrpflicht gemäss
gesetzeslage vorziehen werden
mit welchem gefühl in velten
wohlbefinden mit welchen vorstellungen
vom punkt des her
was wird ihnen von der groeben kaserne
in der militärischen ausbildung erwarten
ich sage sie sieht mit einem 3d bild von
damals eingerückt nämlich wie war es
damals
damals der soldaten leben vom vater
damals kontodaten des großvaters damals
von soldaten leben des urgroßvaters
sie haben seit erster märz nur
mittlerweile vier wochen hier in der von
der kaserne die militärische ausbildung
genossen das bundesheer kennengelernt
die kaserne ordnung kennengelernt der
soldaten leben kennengelernt
ich sage sie haben ein sehr modernes
attraktives kompetentes und es her
hierbei aufklärungs und
artilleriebataillon 7 der sieht jäger
private in der vordergrund kaserne
feldbach kennengelernt sie haben viel
neues viel interessantes erlebt wie zum
beispiel den exerziert dienst mit viel
selbstdisziplin den laufschritt und
etwas tempo den alltag zu bekommen den
waffen an she's dienst mit schafskäse
mit ihren einsatz waffe den wachdienst
für personen- und fahrzeugkontrollen
gefechts dienst im gelände mit tarnen
und täuschen mit gelände angepasst sich
zu bewegen
der militärischen sport für individuelle
fitness das sehr gute essen in der
kaserne feldbach die kasernierung in der
militärischen unterkunft
die zimmer ordnung die spielordnung den
schutz und die gelebte kameradschaft und
gerade die gelebte kameradschaft haben
sie freunde gewonnen als ihr
stellvertreter der bataillonskommandant
natürlich allen grund der dänen
gratulieren denn sie haben ihre
ausbildungs ziele erreicht sie haben die
basisausbildung kehren bestanden dass
steffen der bataillonskommandant darf
ich die ersten aufklärungskampagne
gratulieren denn sie hat den ausbildungs
auftrag erfüllt haben euer herz als
kompaniekommandant jan hofer als jux
kommunen die herren gruppen kommandanten
und ausbildner ein dankeschön auftrag
erfüllt kamera gut gemacht ich wünsche
ihnen zugelosten grund verdienen in der
stärke von 50 soldaten inklusive einer
soldatin nämlich in der zuordnung 29
herrn rekruten vom auf dem capitol und
sieben feldbach eine frau rekrut
ebenfalls von aufgaben 7 und 7 feldbach
und 20 herren quoten von zwölf aus der
region amstetten
ich wünsche ihnen weiterhin für die
nächsten fünf monate ihre wehrpflicht
als funktionspartei alles gute und viel
soldatenglück horrido und zugleich
[Musik]
der choral der battle of salisbury
leitet über zu den geistlichen worten
der beiden militärs militärseelsorger
die geistlichen worte spricht militär
kaplan magister johannes freitag und das
gebet militärpfarrer manfred war gramm
wird der private kommandant geschätzter
stellvertretender bataillonskommandeur
liebe kameraden kameraden liebe
angehörige über den stream mit uns
verbunden in dieser besonderen stunde
besonders aber liebe an zugenommenen
rekruten ich selber denke ein wenig
bewegt zurück an den vorgang wenn ich
mein ganz persönliches ich gelobe
gesprochen habe nach einer sehr
kompakten ausbildungswoche und
grundausbildung in der land- werker
seine sankt michael beim jägerbataillon
und ich habe mir gefragt mir die frage
gestellt was bedeutet eigentlich ein
gelöbnis was bedeutet es wenn jemand
sagt ich gelobe gerade vorige woche
haben wir im lebens konnte ich im
unterricht darüber nachgedacht wofür
stehe ich was ist mir etwas wert und ich
glaube auch ein gelöbnis hat für uns
unserer gesellschaft für unser land
einen ganz hohen wert besonders das
gelöbnis dieser stunde dass sie ganz
persönlich sprechen
ein gelöbnis ist wohl ein persönliches
versprechen nämlich treu bleiben möchte
mit all meinen kräften ein gelöbnis und
das was ich damit verbinde ist ein ideal
auf das ich mich immer wieder hin
ausrichten kann
gerade auch im alltäglichen im
kameradschaftlichen tun und das
versprechen wir gesagt hat mit treue zu
tun und treue das wird meistens von
anderen wahrgenommen man sagt er nicht
ich bin so treu sondern man sagt der ist
wirklich treuer der ist sich wirklich
treu und treue kommt vom vertrauen dem
sich an vertrauen einander etwas
zutrauen ein anderes wort wäre wohl auch
treue kommt aus der erfahrung
wir können uns aufeinander verlassen und
das sind wir mittendrin in der
kameradschaft den dem was uns verbindet
unabhängig von freundschaften sympathien
in der kameradschaft kommt es darauf an
dass ich das mir mögliche tun dass ich
nach meinen kräften das von mir als
notwendig erkannte einbringe und das
weitere das erfahren wir in der übung
auch im ernstfall in assistenz einsetzen
dass weitere wird sich fügen
wenn jeder das ihm mögliche tut das als
notwendig erkannte einbringt dann wird
sich das weitere fügen wird weiteres
angeleitet ist so manches auch angeführt
ein glaubender mensch unabhängig welcher
konfession und religion der vertieft
diese erfahrung noch einmal und vertraut
darauf dass gott in den situationen wo
wir dass unser mögliche tun aber nichts
weiter in der hand haben können dass
gottes ist ergänzt und begleitet und das
liebe kameraden kameraden ist mein
wunsch an diesem besonderen tag in
dieser besonderen stunde ihres lebens
aber auch unseres gemeinsamen lebens
ich wünsche ihnen ganz persönlich dass
es ihnen gelingt dem heutigen wert ihres
gelöbnisses treu zu sein und dass diese
erfahrung der sechs monate oder
vielleicht auch einer längeren zeit
ihnen hilfe ist sich auf so manches
gelöbnis ihres lebens einzuüben im blick
auf den menschen im blick auf eine
freundschaft im blick auf eine
überzeugung wenn jeder einzelne jede
einzelne sich mit das mögliche zu tun
können wir aus dem glauben heraus sagen
mit überzeugung wird gott auch so
manches fügen führen ergänzen und
vollenden
in dieser stunde wünsche ich ihnen
wünschen wir euch gott möge sich
schützen und segnen in den kommenden
monaten ihres dienstes für unser land
und über diese prägende zeit ihres
lebens sind aus diesen segen dürfen wir
bitten wenn einer eine reise tut dann
kann aber fair' zählen
so schreibt es der deutsche dichter
matthias claudius
dabei hängt es verein davon ab wer reist
und wir selbst eine fremde umgebung
erlebt er schaut und wahrnimmt auch sie
liebe gruppen haben vor einem monat eine
reise ich sage mal ins ungewisse
angetreten und er hoffe dass in fünf
monaten vieles und vor allem positive
erlebnis und das schaut es zu erzählen
haben
dafür möchte ich ihnen gottes segen mit
geben es ist ein alter irischer
reisesegen der glaube ich sehr gut zu
uns soldaten passt daher sei vor dir und
mir den rechten weg zu zeigen
die hälfte neben dir und ich in die arme
zu nehmen und vor gefahren zu schützen
daher sei hinter dir um dich vor der
heimtücke des bösen zu bewahren
der herr sei unter dir und ich
aufzufangen wenn du fällst der herr sei
india und nicht vertrösten wenn du
traurig bist
daher sei um dich herum um sich zu
verteidigen wenn andere über die
herfallen und daher sehr über die um
dich zu segnen und vor segne und behüte
euch alle unabhängig von
version und religion der mächtige und
barmherzige gott der vater der sohn und
der heilige geist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja das ist ein sehr schwungvoll das
musikstück der jäger mag es seit der
debatte zum höchsten militärischen der
präsidentin des heutigen tages er ist
immerhin kommandanten über 5200 soldaten
das aktiv und des militantes und zivile
verdienste des österreichischen
bundesheeres und wir bitten um ihre
gedanken herr brigadier magister horst
hofer sehr der patrons kommandantur
geistlichkeit vertreter der
personalvertretung offiziere unter für
ihre chancen rekruten und ganz besonders
meine jüngsten kameraden und
kameradinnen des entwicklungs termin
märz mit ihren angehörigen die uns
entweder über livestream zu schauen oder
wie ich annehme
ein oder andere sogar über den kasernen
sound dieser veranstaltung beiwohnte das
irritiert sich aus der garnison feldbach
begrüßen
eine junge kameraden zu den letzten
wochen ließ der batterie husqvarna
erwähnt hat vieles neues gelernt er hat
auch auf den punkt der kameradschaft
hingewiesen und das ist einer jener
bereiche wo ihr gelernt habt dass man
schwierige aufgaben nicht immer alleine
lösen muss sondern das schwierige
aufgaben leichter zu lösen sind wenn man
es gemeinsam macht und wenn man sich
dabei gegenseitig unterstützt
sie haben die grund tätigkeiten des
militärischen handwerk erlernt sie
werden in weiterer folge hier in
feldbach oder auch in amstetten beim
jägerbataillon zwölfter leichten pro
jahr ihren dienst versehen sie werden
ihre ausbildung als soldat als soldatin
weiterführen und komplettieren
das ist es auch was von der
österreichischen bevölkerung von uns als
österreichisches bundesheer von uns als
soldaten erwartet wird dass wir über
fähigkeiten verfügen die es uns auch
ermöglichen die österreichische
bevölkerung dann zu schützen wenn es
andere nicht mehr können
zum zweiten ermöglicht es diese
ausbildung diese militärische ausbildung
ihnen und ich gehe davon aus dass einige
von ihnen in den einsatz gehen werden
die unterstützung einsätze für die
gesundheits- und sicherheitsbehörden
sowie ihre kameraden derzeit sind über
1100 soldaten sollen das sind negative
im inland oder auch im ausland im
einsatz zu erfüllen sie werden mit ihrer
dienstleistung es ermöglichen dass wir
als träger das hat die
aufklärungsbataillon 7 das
jägerbataillon 12 in den nächsten
monaten die von uns erwarteten aufgaben
erfüllen wird und der vorgesehene
leistungen erbringen werden ich wünsche
ihnen für diese kommende zeit für diese
kommenden fünf monate viel soldatenglück
viel erfolg bauen sie auf das auf was in
den letzten wochen bereits gezeigt haben
und in beeindruckender weise um sie
folgendes immer wieder bewiesen dass sie
sich in die gestellten aufgaben als
mensch als person voll einbringen
und wer dazu in der lage ist der sind
mein gewinner bleiben sie daher auf der
gewinner spur bringen sie sich auch
weiterhin ein wie ihr das
österreichische bundesheer dass abdi 70
rabatt von 12 aber vor allem die
österreichische bevölkerung zählen
darauf als regale kommen
wird es wenn es notwendig ist meine
aufgabe sein mit ihnen gemeinsam in
einsatz zu gehen
gerade für die militärischen einsätze
ist es von elementarer bedeutung dass
wir uns gegenseitig vertrauen können
daher ist es für mich jetzt eine
besondere ehre und auszeichnung mit
ihnen gemeinsam das neue gelernt ist
gelernt sich sprechen zu dürfen und so
wird der insignia druck vom ausland 70
zentimeter des platzes begeben mit der
fahne spitze zu den rekruten nicht auf
einen die akteure vorstellen mallorca
facebook kommentaren von fahnenoffizier
fahnenträger auf ihr stellvertreter rené
pfalz und fahnenoffizier major martin
meyer
ausgesucht wurden bereits zwei rekruten
und jenny verurteilt aus sankt stefan im
rosental mit die dienststelle hier in
feldbach bleiben und rekrut februar
helen aus sankt leonhard am walde wird
nach niederösterreich gehen zum jäger
patron 12 und die angelobung formel wird
sprechen der herberger der magister
horst hofer das ganze acht den segen dem
schritt macht
[Musik]
die rekruten vortreten eingeteilte
rekruten im schrittmaß der rekruten
high-end-geräte rekruten rechts und
links um
an zu geloben der rekruten zum sehr
guten auf mein kommando das treu
geblieben das ist nach zu sprechen
ich gelobe mein vater an die republik
österreich
und sein volk zu schützen und mit der
waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe den gesetzen
und den gesetzmäßigen behörden treue und
gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
hektisch und genau zu befolgen und mit
allen meinen kräften der republik
österreich und dem österreichischen volk
zu dienen angelobte rekruten form der
eingeteilte rekruten rechts und links um
eingeteilt die rekruten im schrittmaß
[Musik]
eingeteilt der rekruten
mit dem schritt macht das ganze ja liebe
eltern familienangehörige freunde die
heute dabei waren sie können wirklich
stolz seiner für den sohn
beziehungsweise erde tochter es war eine
perfekte angelobung formel
protokollarische ändert es musikalisch
mittelland der sünde
während zu präsentieren zum abspielen
der bundeshymne das ganze rechts schaut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ganze acht ehrenzug gewehr ab das
ganze gut
der comandante ausgedrückten truppe
meldeten private kommentaren die
beendigung der angelobung feuer und
wasser folgt reza bieten weitere befehle
das ganze erde zu pressen wird zum
anbieten weiterer befehle das ganze
rechts schaut
wie reagiere ich melde die beendigung
des festaktes der angelobung und bitte
um weitere befehle
april
ass
der bezug gewehr ab das ganze offiziell
endete der festakt jetzt mit dem
ausmarsch der standarte das ganze habe
affären zu präsentieren zum ausmaß des
insignia trupps das ganze rechts
insignia tobt im schritt was
[Musik]
er entzog gewehr ab das ganze ja das war
es von der heutigen angelobung danke dem
team von reportern 74 unterstützung und
danke dem team der harrah's bild und
film stelle aus wien unter der leitung
von amtsdirektor wolfgang hahn ja das
war's genießen sie das wochenende das
wünschen ineffizient karl heinz becker
auf wiedersehen